Guatemala hoy por hoy diversos sectores
no solamente a la élite empresarial sino
aquí creo que hay que verlo en una
dimensión un poco más amplia y yo en lo
particular no me caso mucho con ese
concepto de pacto de corruptos porque
Trata de ser como muy estático y no
plantea realmente la dinámica del poder
en el país pero digo esto Solo como
paréntesis el tema de las hijas visto
como una anomalía es decir como un como
un capítulo de La historia que ya ya
pasaron varias páginas y que por lo
tanto hoy por hoy la mayoría de personas
implicadas en todos los casos que develó
el exige conjunto con el Ministerio
Público en su época esos casos ya fueron
cerrados la mayoría de ellos muchos ya
salieron de la cárcel por supuesto en
medio de una serie de anomalías y en
medio de todo ese control ahora lo que
vivimos en el país es como el extremo es
decir todos los todos los actores que
estuvieron involucrados y todas las
instituciones que en su momento
respaldaron
hay un corrimiento digamos el Polo Se
movió del otro lado y por lo tanto
vivimos otra vez una escalada de
impunidad e inclusive ahora marcada por
el agregado de la venganza es decir
Tomar venganza de todos aquellos actores
operadores de Justicia investigadores de
la del Ministerio Público todos aquellos
que contribuyeron a esa de actos de
develación de corrupción Ahora son los
que están ya sea fuera del país en el
exilio o bien también purgando en la
cárcel o a punto de entrar en procesos
que estarían inclusive todavía en
volverse en los siguientes meses Así que
lo que vemos es un movimiento
insisto del otro lado y la el tema no
está en la agenda electoral porque el el
ponerle la agenda electoral implica en
buena medida no contar con el
beneplácito de ese conjunto de actores
no solo élites sino también actores
criminales que también ahora han hecho
Alianza y por lo tanto
no es un tema que no se toca como tal si
se toca el tema de la corrupción pero se
toca quizás con digamos con guante de
seda no con la suficiente contundencia
que vaya acorde con la complejidad y la
profundidad del fenómeno Así que diría
que el tema se sigue está presente pero
básicamente es el movimiento anticipo el
que está protagonizando hoy por hoy en
varias de las opciones electorales que
se están por hoy compitiendo en arbola
son los que encabezan todo la el
planteamiento ese planteamiento sí es
uno de los adhesivos de esa esos
partidos que buscan más menos la la
continuidad la continuidad dicho así
siempre y cuando no se combata la
corrupción siempre y cuando inclusive se
pueda potenciar las redes de corrupción
como lo han hecho las dos
administraciones recientes la de morales
y la actual